former NFL linebacker Blake Martinez has
been accused of being a big time Pokemon
card scammer after retiring from the NFL
Martinez got into the Pokemon card
business and he's made 11.5 million
dollars reselling the cards and he did
that in less than a year he was able to
sell one Pikachu illustrator card for
672 thousand dollars one card and he has
nearly 20 full-time staffers at his
company well maybe not anymore since an
investigation took place which found
Martinez guilty a Reddit user accused
him of swapping out expensive Pokemon
cards for cheaper ones and another
Reddit user claimed he won two slabs off
Martinez's live stream and neither of
them were shipped one of the top
reselling platforms whatnot has
permanently removed Martinez from their
platforms along with the employees who
were also involved the platform has
refunded all the buyers who are affected
by Martinez's sale